let's move on to nancy pelosi
and nancy pelosi lord nancy pelosi you
know i left california to escape people
like nancy pelosi but she still pops up
on the video machine
here she is talking about republicans
those scary republicans and january 6th
what the republicans are doing across
the country is really a a legislative
continue continuation of what they did
on january 6 which is to undermine
our democracy to uh undermine the
integrity of our elections uh to uh
undermine the
uh
the voting power which is the essence of
a democracy okay before i get into the
substance of what she just said there
which was pure nonsense uh i hope that
connor you can put up a still image of
nancy pelosi from that video that we
just saw there so people can look at her
eyebrows what in god's name is happening
there that is not a human face
the alien is bursting forth i don't know
if that's a facelift or an eye lift or a
whatever i don't begrudge her her
ability to do whatever she wants but
these people are crazy and they're
starting to look crazy joe biden also
looks crazy from all the work the
tightening and the pulling and the hair
plugs and the dentures yeah why are we
governed by these geriatric buffoons but
now let's get to the to the substance of
what she said uh of course a few days
ago was the anniversary of the january
6th insurrection which is the most
orgasmic holiday that democrats and
their media cohorts will ever have and
each year they will
just jizz all over themselves as they
talk about it it's quite disgusting
sorry sorry michael um
uh but what she's saying there is oh
they tried to take over the government
with their insurrection on january 6 and
yeah sure nobody brought any weapons
they had no plans one guy maybe had a
lego set of the capital it turned out
that wasn't even true i'm not defending
anyone that broke the law you can't just
break windows and attack police officers
and everything else but there was a lot
of just like let's just walk in and see
what's what i'm not even getting into
any of that nonsense it was done in
three hours aoc's life was never
under threat or anything else like that
but what she's saying is what they're
doing now is a legislative continuation
of what they did on january 6. so what
is it
nancy that republicans are doing with
these election bills well they're doing
things like ensuring that people have to
have ids to vote
making sure that you can't
canvas right outside polling stations
making sure that mail-in ballots are
more secure making sure that we don't
change election laws right before
elections a whole bunch of really same
stuff unlike the story we covered
yesterday in new york city where they're
going to allow
800 000 people 800 000 people who have
been in the united states illegally for
more than 30 days they're going to be
allowed to vote we're not going to check
ids and the rest of it so everything
that they say is a lie it's so weird
right it really is like a weird thing
like what is that are you human at some
level if every day you get up
publicly and you just lie about
everything she knows she's lying and by
the way this is this is where the media
always drops the ball because whoever
was interviewing her there it's like
look i'm an interviewer and everyone can
criticize
interviewers everyone has a different
style and everything else but it's like
an interviewer should follow up and be
like all right well what you're saying
there is you're claiming that the
republicans are trying an insurrection
via the legislative branch with these
laws that they're passing so what is it
about showing voter id uh that is so
evil right like what is it about making
sure that citizens only allowed to vote
that are so evil like they should be
pushed on these things and and they
rarely are
all that being said there's obviously an
alien somewhere in pelosi it could burst
forth from her stomach that's the
traditional way that aliens burst forth
but this alien seems to be bursting
forth from her face remember that scene
in uh
in men in black when the alien comes
down and it takes over the guy and he
wants sugar water or lemonade or
something right at the beginning and
he's pulling on his face that's what
she's starting to look like i think you
know what i'm talking about connor can
we get that image you know i'm talking
about the guy he's pulling his face you
want sugar water
okay